all right everybody what is going on
welcome back to another robotics with
python tutorial video in this video
we're actually going to start uh
programming
our motors on our raspberry pi here in
our car so if you recall we actually
already do have a script uh from before
which was stored in our robotics
directory so i'm going to cd into
robotics
and that was robot1.pi so first let's go
ahead and just run that and actually
first let's view it just so we can see
it one more time sudo nano
robot
one dot pi to bring it up
and this was the file just so you all
remember
this is just setting up
the
the board the output pins and then this
was just
a quick test basically of our robots so
let's exit that and now let's go ahead
and do sudo python robot1.pi
and we run that
and we can see that one side of our
wheels do indeed do run because that's
kind of how just how we programmed it
but now what we want to do is we want to
start programming the other wheels we
want all the we want the wheels to work
together to move forward backwards and
even though we don't have a pivot we can
make just one side of wheels go to make
us turn kind of like we just did now
right so this would make it turn if
forward was to continue right this would
make it turn left a little bit right if
this was the only side that turned we
can also make this side uh
roll that way but then the other side
rolled the other way and that would make
it actually pivot instead of turning
so there's definitely like a lot of
things that we can do and we just need
to program that in so first let's go
ahead and
let's do some basic uh forward and
backwards so to do that i'm actually
going to start a new script entirely and
then we'll continue building off of this
one so let's go ahead and do sudo nano
uh and we want to let's call this
robot2.pi
hit enter empty file first things that
we want to do is go ahead and import
capital r capital p lowercase i dot caps
gpio
as lowercase gpio for ourselves and make
it easy and then we'll also import time
now we want to do is every time
we run a command we want to run an
initialization
for a couple of different reasons
but this will only really be apparent
down the road right now it might not
make much sense to why we are doing this
but just kind of follow along and we'll
get there so first we want to have a
definition
this function is going to be called init
for initiate
and in this function if you're by the
way if you're programming through like
using nano on your pi
when you hit enter it's not going to
automatically indent like most of your
ides are going to do an indent typically
on python is one two three four spaces
so just keep that in mind so continuing
on we wanna do gpio dot set mode and we
wanna set the mode
gpio dot
board
once that's done one two three four the
next thing that we want to do is uh we
want to set up the pins just like we had
before so that's gonna be 7 11 13 and
15. so gpio.setup
7 and that's going to be a
gpio it's gotta be in caps out then
we're gonna go ahead and do gpio setup
11
gpi
oops gpio out
gpio setup
13 gpio
out and
finally gpio setup
15 gpio dot
out and that's going to be our
initialization function that's all we
want within it now we want to have is
some sort of function that makes
everything go forward so to do that
let's go ahead and define
forward
and forward is first going to do
initialization
so it sets everything as output and
nothing else really it just initializes
for us and now what we want to do is
gpio
dot output
and
13 will be true 15 false 7 false and 11
true
and let's i guess we can make this a
little easier let's do seven
false
gpio.output
11
true
then
13 will also be true output
13
true
and then gpiota output
15
will be false
okay
so that's it for forward now the other
thing that we should do
is in our function we should have one
parameter and we'll call it tf which is
short for time frame like how long do we
want this function to actually run for
so
then after we run this
we're going to do a time dot sleep for
the time frame
and then after that we're going to do a
gpio.cleanup
and that's going to stop the pins from
running and that's kind of why we want
to
uh oh what has happened okay i guess
we're scrolling up here i try to use my
scroll
that didn't work very well anyway uh
that's why we have that initialization
up here anyways continuing along um
that's it for forward and that should be
all we need so now we can actually call
forward and then we'll save for one
second so let's go ahead and do control
x whoops control x yes to save and we'll
take that same name now let's go ahead
and do sudo python robot2.pi hit enter
and sure enough all the wheels spun in a
forward direction together in unison
and again
and now would be a really good time if
you have some painters tape or some
scotch tape or something um well i guess
not really scotch tape but some painters
tape
draw a little arrow on the paint or the
tape rather and put that on the frame so
i'm going to do that real quick
okay so now i have an arrow that that
kind of indicates to me what direction
is meant to be forward that way we
always know that we're doing it right
now the other thing i will just mention
is i have kind of everything just kind
of screwed there i meant to bring this
up
initially
but
you do want to kind of watch your cables
and your stuff and like your cords
because if they get caught in the wheel
it's going to spin up in the wheel and
it's you might rip something out or you
know you definitely don't want to break
you know the wires are cheap but you
wouldn't want to like
break something off the soldering and
stuff so anyways
be careful about that the other thing i
do is keep like the battery pack out
because if you can't get it to stop it's
usually quicker just to reach over and
unplug a battery and that will stop your
motors
rather than going back into your code
fixing the problem and then re-running
it just to get it to stop or running you
know cleanup or something so anyways
just wanted to bring that up so forward
worked how would we get it to go
backwards so let's go ahead and go sudo
nano robot2.pi
let's get back in there
and now let's go all the way to the
bottom and now what we want to do is
define well let's go past forward here
let's just put it right here so define
uh and we're going to call this reverse
time frame is our parameter one two
three four in it of course
and now what we wanna do
is we wanna have gpio
dot
output and this time seven is gonna rain
true
and now gpio output
11
is going to be false
and then
gpio.output
13. do you think everything is a reverse
completely of itself falls and then
finally gpi.output 15 the moment of
truth did we just flip everything
true we sure did
anyway that's reverse so now let's go
ahead and run a reverse for one second
so now what's going to happen when you
do this is it will go forward for a
second and then flip the motors back and
go in reverse so let's say or exit save
yep and then up arrow twice to run
robot2 hit enter
and it ran but what did we forget to do
we forgot to clean up so
i'm going to pull out that battery and
this is a good reason why
that's why we did that anyway sudo nano
robot 2. pi
uh come down here
and after the time well first of all we
didn't even have a time sleep we were
really bad here time dot sleep
for the time frame
and then we want to run
let me just get it up there gpio.cleanup
just like the other script so
gpio.cleanup
so we want to run that
yes
enter and i'm just going to run it real
quick without putting that battery back
in so hopefully everything will get
cleaned up
and then we'll do it again one more time
okay let's try that again
much better so now we've got to forward
and reverse so now what else might we
want to do well we might want to program
in a turn or we might want to program a
pivot so that's what we're going to do
in the next couple videos is we're going
to program in the turn in the pivot so
that's what you have to look forward to
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time